bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 20 octobre
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition de cette 8e le journal
on commence tôt fit avec les titres de
votre actualité locale et le conseil
départemental entend réorganiser les
centres de protection maternelle et
infantile les pmi afin d'optimiser les
moyens dans plusieurs communes à la
verrière ou encore à guyancourt
les élus de gauche s'inquiète nous
recevons ce soir laurence trochut
conseillère départementale les
républicains l'association yvelinoise
achève prévention proposées depuis
vendredi dernier le premier jeu
interactif et ludique sur la lutte
contre le sida vi reçoit un jeu éducatif
et préventif qui s'achève aujourd'hui 20
octobre place de la bastille à paris et
chaque année à montigny le bretonneux
l'événement armanet permet de valoriser
arts picturaux sculptures et photos
c'est aussi l'occasion de récolter des
fonds contre la maladie d'alzheimer
retour sur la dernière édition qui se
tenait ce week-end pénalisé pour avoir
prescrit trop d'indemnités journalières
c'est la situation dans lequel se
retrouvent dans laquelle se retrouve le
docteur véronique molaires lire un
collectif de médecins et de patients
s'étaient rassemblés vers 15h devant la
castration ce maladie de versailles pour
soutenir le médecin généraliste de magny
les hameaux
la cpam lui reproche d'avoir prescrit
trop d'arrêts de travail une situation
injuste selon celles qui exercent dans
une commune qui compte trois médecins
pour 10000 habitants on écoute nous ont
pas du tout tenu compte de mon activité
du nombre de patients que j'ai du nombre
de médecins qu'on est dans la cour on
est trois pour 10000 habitants de la
pathologie qu'on les jambes ça je
l'aurais raconter mais ça l'aurait
affaibli ce qu'ils ont sanctionné
durement en demandant pratiquement 25% -
donc me demander de diminuer de 25 % les
indemnités journalières c'est tout
simplement nous faire diminuer de façon
arbitraire
donc c'est où mettre les gens à la porte
ou les choisir en fonction de leur
pathologie donc ça c'est non une
situation préoccupante pour les
syndicats de médecins nombre d'entre eux
seraient concernés par un problème comme
celui ci le directeur de la caisse
d'assurance maladie rendra son avis
d'ici six semaines sur la sanction à
l'encontre du docteur véronique molères
et comment bien manger c'est une
question que vous vous posez de plus en
plus souvent jusqu'au 23 octobre à
trappes sur le court se trouve justement
la quinzaine de la nutrition de semaine
placée sous le signe de l' équilibre
alimentaire
au programme spectacles ateliers et
conférences pour apprendre à bien
remplir son assiette petit aperçu avec
deux ateliers l'un sur l'importance du
petit déjeuner et le second sur comment
retrouver du plaisir en mangeant en
étant diabétique william l il faut que
les pins le débourrage fin c'est pas un
seul enfant a refusé une fois deux fois
on la rêve c'est le repas le plus
important de la journée mais il est
souvent difficile de le faire entendre
aux enfants dans le cadre de la
quinzaine de la nutrition à trappes de
nombreux ateliers autour de l' équilibre
alimentaire était programmée aujourd'hui
les parents apprennent comment faire
prendre aux enfants
un vrai petit déjeuner
ce qui est important c'est déjà de
s'hydrater boire de l'eau ou un jus de
fruit ou verdelais thé tisane et d'avoir
un apport en sucre
donc on va porter avec les féculents oui
j'ai appris des choses vraiment prendre
en compte
chacun chaque paroisse est vraiment se
dire que y'a pas mode d'emploi en fait
on on accompagne on n'est pas là
forcément on pourra apporter la solution
aux parents balle au fond parce qu'au
final faut vraiment reconnaître leurs
compétences à eux est essentielle pour
éviter les coups de fatigue ou les
malaises le contenu de ce repas compte
moins que sa régularité
le plus important c'est de le prendre
tous les matins deux jours plus tard
anne valérie anime un autre atelier
autour du diabète cette fois devant un
autre public dans une maison de retraite
l'alimentation du diabétique en fait
c'est l'alimentation équilibrée 1 par
excellence donc ne pas sauter de repas
faire trois ou quatre pas en fonction de
son rythme en général les personnes qui
font du diabète ne veulent absolument
pas se prendre un dessin parce que il ya
elle se prive de sucre or pas forcément
peut parfaitement en manger un petit
dessert au sein de repas équilibrés
un atelier qui permet de casser les
idées reçues autour de cette maladie et
réconcilier les diabétiques avec
certains aliments de nombreux événements
ont été organisés pour cette semaine de
la nutrition qui se terminera jeudi avec
un grand jeu pour toute la famille
versoirs débarque en france
l'association hf prévention a lancé
vendredi dernier le premier jeu
interactif sur la lutte contre le sida
située place de la bastille jusqu'à ce
soir le jeu présenté sous la forme d'art
lasergame géant invite les participants
à détruire le virus du sida à l'aide
d'un pistolet laser un nouveau moyen
plus ludique pour sensibiliser au
dépistage regardé changer les
comportements tout en s'amusant c'est
maintenant possible avec virus war le
jeu interactif lancé par hachette
prévention place les participants à
l'intérieur d'un être humain
fonctionnant sur le principe de
lasergame les joueurs équipés de fusils
d'assaut ont pour mission de détruire le
virus du sida virus soir c'est
relativement simple les gens viennent on
va les miniaturiser
on va les injecter dans une personne qui
est nouvellement donc séropositives et
ils vont pouvoir essayer et tenté de
tuer le virus du sida à coups de
pistolet laser et chaque petit tir de
pistolet laser permet effectivement donc
d'avoir des tirs de trithérapie chaque
détail compte pour une immersion
complète dès leur arrivée les
participants sont équipés et visionne un
film qui les conditionne dans un univers
futuriste pour cause les jeunes restent
la cible principale de cet événement les
jeunes qui protège le moindre -
paraît-il
donc je crois que j'ai plus ou très
important de de pouvoir façon ludique
je sais un peu le propos de montrer que
les trophées rasions est protégé je me
souviens plus si j'étais capitaine
sergent je sais plus fraîches de
désordre en tout cas dans le désordre de
donner des ordres
un champ de bataille de 250 m² dans
lequel est plongé le joueur dans le noir
principalement un enchevêtrement de
sallesobscures symbolisant les organes
humains un sujet grave pour une
expérience qui elle se fait dans la
bonne humeur
je pense que pour les jeunes ce sera
bien savent et sensibilisera vachement
c'est super et c'est pas toujours facile
de tuer les virus donc attention chaque
année en france et plus de 7000
nouvelles personnes qui sont
diagnostiquées séropositives et 30000
qui ignorent leur statut virus soir une
grande première en europe qui devrait
voir le jour dans d'autres villes
françaises est l'événement ce terme est
donc que ce soit à 20h pour jérôme
montrer directeur de h r prévention
c'est déjà un succès car plus de 3700
personnes se sont rendus place de la
bastille pour s'essayer au jeu d'autres
villes de france et aussi en europe
serait intéressé pour accueillir elle
aussi le team verygames virus war et
enfin sachez que ce soir gérard filoche
élu au bureau national du parti
socialiste et ancien inspecteur du
travail donnera une conférence à la
verrière sur le thème de l'emploi et
notamment des politiques publiques
proposées depuis 30 ans quant à anne
hidalgo anne hidalgo pardon elle n'est
plus la bienvenue à maisons-laffitte
dans les yvelines ce lundi jacques
milliards le maire les républicains de
la ville également député de la 5e
circonscription des yvelines a signé un
arrêté municipal portant sur
l'interdiction de séjour sur le
territoire de sa commune
la mère du parti socialiste à paris une
décision en rapport avec les annonces de
cette dernière de rendre piétonnière
piétonnière la voie sur berge sur la
rive droite de la seine
l'arrêté peut bien évidemment faire
l'objet d'un recours vous en douter mais
jacques myard a prévu de lever si la
mère décide d'abandonner son projet
siens il est temps à présent de passer à
notre entretien laurence trochut bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes conseillère
départementale des yvelines vous êtes en
plateau avec nous ce soir pour parler de
la réorganisation des pmi des protection
maternelle infantile alors sur les 60
pmi seule une vingtaine devraient être
conservés c'est une décision du conseil
départemental
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu cette
décision alors c'est une décision qui a
effectivement été prise et qui en fait
trouve deux raisons voilà parce qu'en
fait on s'est rendu compte que les
services de pmi pouvait être amélioré ça
fait plusieurs années déjà que le
département il travaille pour essayer de
comprendre un peu comment comment les
formules pourrait mieux satisfaire les
besoins de la population et donc c'est
pmi on vise en fait de les optimiser
c'est à dire de permettre une ouverture
pas simplement quelques demi-journées
par semaine comme c'est actuellement le
cas
mais des ouvertures 5 jours sur 7
parfois même le samedi on vise aussi des
délais d'attentes pour les pour être
reçus qu'ils soient moins longues parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'actuellement il ya
à peu près des délais de deux mois et
demi pour avoir un rendez vous il y en
aura kamke une vingtaine qui vont être
conservées sur 60 donc même si elles
sont ouverts plus longtemps
on imagine mal comment ça peut être plus
efficace alors ça peut être plus
efficace parce que ça veut dire qu'en
fait les équipes médicales seront
concentrées sur effectivement certains
centres de pmi à la journée donc déjà il
y aura pas de perte de transport pour
pour les personnels de santé et les
c'est à dire qu'il ya des études pour
être placé à certains moments en fait il
y aura une stabilité des équipes des
équipes médicales parce que
effectivement actuellement les équipes
elles doivent se balader d'un centre à
un autre
encore une fois sur des demi journées
donc sur des créneaux qui sont très
restreints tandis que là on aura une
ouverture complète à la journée avec une
équipe médicale qui elle aussi sera
sera constitué de tous les intervenants
aussi bien puéricultrice que médecin il
était en gauche il ya des gens qui ont
peut-être l'essentiel non il ya en fait
il ya un maintien complet d'aidé
personnelle donc il n'ya pas deux il n'y
a pas de suppressions ni de personnel ni
de service donc parler de fermeture de
pmi c'est faux en fait ce qui va être
réorganisée effectivement ce sont les
locaux de pmi mais il n'y a absolument
pas de fermetures de services de pmi qui
donc la fermeture de la famille de bilan
pourrait de la verrière à des fermetures
sont des réorganisations les gens qui se
rendront ces locaux ne trouveront plus
le pen est quoi alors ils trouveront ils
n'ont en fait la raison pour laquelle on
ne peut pas maintenir les locaux dans
l'état actuel c'est qu'en fait les
locaux sont inadaptés
quand évidemment on a une ouverture sur
quelques heures dans une dans une
semaine
ça peut suffire quand en revanche on a
une ouverture et une
professionnalisation cinq jours sur sept
les locaux deviennent deuxième trop
petit alors 60 % sont ouverts
actuellement sa suppression des pénis on
verra comment deux jours par semaine
c'est quand même peu la mutualisation va
se faire comment est-ce qu'il va y avoir
des pmi qui vont être voilà attribué
pour certains patients ou certains je
sais pas peut-être domaine de maintenant
parce que faut pas oublier faut pas
perdre de vue que la pmi son premier
rôle c'est la prévention
donc en fait le service de pmi c'est pas
un service d'urgence avec des
spécialités qui correspondrait à
certaines pathologies
ça reste une approche généraliste et en
ce sens tous les services de prêts et me
propose propose les mêmes les mêmes
services alors c'est une décision avant
tout économique
comme nous l'expliqué anne capio je vous
propose de l'écouter tout de suite on a
plus les moyens
baisses de dotations de l'état ça
représente pour le conseil départemental
cent cinquante mille 100 150 millions
d'euros sur trois ans 10 % du budget on
peut pas si on peut pas continuer à
financer des structures de services
publics en bas de chaque habitation
c'est pas possible donc on mutualisent
on améliore le service pour les gens la
veille un vrai un vrai déficit à combler
il faut vraiment réaliser comment c'est
possible de faire pareil avec
- justement on va pas faire pareil on va
faire mieux et c'est pour ça que les
deux raisons celle que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure à savoir une réorganisation pour
une meilleure qualité de service il faut
pas là il faut pas la perdre de vue
certes on est dans un contexte de budget
extrêmement restreint mais il faut pas
oublier que cette réorganisation elle
était prévue avant même que y ait ces
coupes budgétaires au programme
tout simplement parce que le département
c'est se remettre en cause quand il le
faut serrer adapter son offre aux
besoins aux besoins du terrain et donc
cette réorganisation que nous voulons
mener pour une meilleure qualité dans la
mesure où on a des contraintes
budgétaires
évidemment que comme dit madame capio on
peut pas opté pour une telle solution au
bas de chaque immeuble donc selon vous
auparavant il y avait peut-être des
sommes qui étaient mal mal engagée qui
était peut-être mal dispensés dans les
pmi non c'est pas qu'elle était mal
organisé sur le plan sur le plan
juridique mais c'est ou financier c'est
simplement qu'elle était elle n'était
pas forcément ciblées pour avoir un
champ d'action aussi aussi important
maintenant
et puis il faut pas oublier en plus
qu'il ya un autre élément qui doit être
pris en compte c'est la réorganisation
territoriale
on est maintenant dans un système où
effectivement on raisonne à l'échelle de
l'intercommunalité
donc on ne peut pas continuer à être
centrée uniquement sur sa propre comme
justement comment s'est fait ce décision
de décider voilà qu'elle pmi allait
fermer qu'elle paie l'ami allait être
restée ouverte entre guillemets voile où
elle est très organisée
enfin au niveau des centres vous avez
décidé justement alors justement on a
décidé ça en fonction de critères très
objectifs c'est à dire comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure les locaux
est-ce que les locaux tels qu'ils sont
correspondent ou pas aux besoins et au
cahier des charges que les
professionnels du département ont dressé
il ya aussi la question de
l'accessibilité est ce que pour accéder
à une un service de pmi et je vais
pouvoir facilement avec ma poussette
mes courses etc me rendre où voilà ça
c'est vraiment deux deux critères
importants à prendre en compte et je
pense que vraiment secrétaire de
l'accessibilité il est primordial nous
avons justement a demandé aux cinq ans
noah ce qu'ils en pensent et noir à leur
avons posé la question s'il fallait
réorganiser les pmi je propose de
regarder ces témoignages
je pense que ce serait pas mal de
rattacher
mick certaines des amis avec les centres
de santé à la structure mise en place je
pense qu'il est déjà pas mal
et si il faut demander encore à
réorganiser sa a démandé normand à
mettre beaucoup je peux dire en termes
de lois et tout essayer et voir quelles
sont les priorités dans certains
secteurs
oui il faudrait peut-être regrouper pour
pour essayer que plus de personnes ait
accès justement aux pmi parce que
beaucoup de personnes ne connaissent
peut-être pas donc suffisamment ça
dépend aujourd'hui ça fonctionne assez
bien
c'est vrai que moi je les j'ai utilisé
le service quand j'étais avec les deux
enfants quand ils étaient nés et c'était
intéressant alors je pense que c'est un
bon service et que c'est important de le
garder laurence rochât votre votre
réaction quand vous entendez à ces
témoignages alors un bon service et
c'est important de garder je suis
complètement d'accord et c'est
effectivement pour nous on va pas on va
pas supprimer une formule qui a fait ses
preuves et qui marche donc il est
absolument pas question de supprimer le
service de de pmi je vois quand même que
beaucoup de réactions insiste sur la
mutualisation et en ce sens le
département est complètement moteur dans
ce dans ce projet est assez novateur
aussi par rapport à d'autres
départements
voilà je pense qu'il ya un cadre à
l'intérieur duquel les discussions
restent ouvertes évidemment et est
actuellement par exemple en ce qui
concerne la pmi de guyancourt il ya
trois projets qui sont à l'étude
trois projets que sur lesquels je me
suis vraiment investi aussi bien sur les
critères d'accessibilité comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
moi par exemple j'ai pris mes enfants
suite deux ans dans la poussette celle
de cinq ans accroché à la poussette et
j'ai testé en conditions réelles
lettrage elle le quota de marche à pied
de bus et caetera et de même j'irai
visiter les plateaux qui sont proposés
pour voilà voir les critères objectifs
de discerne justement la pmi de
guyancourt alors il ya des
manifestations pour la sauver elle
devrait également connaître donc fermé
donc être organisées selon vous dire ça
a été annoncé en juin françois des
lignes et le maire ps de bien en cours
était sur notre plateau le 23 septembre
dernier pour en parler je propose
écouter ce que ce qui me disaient ses
propositions pour voilà sauvé entre amis
vous savez dans les propositions que je
formule il ya encore des demi-journées
disponible à guyancourt donc on peut pas
dire on va gagner en mi-journée il
suffit de maintenir la paix mis à
guyancourt et d'augmenter le temps des
permanences et puis si les locaux ne
sont pas suffisants moi je fais des
propositions de locaux plus grands et
j'indique parce que c'est un mauvais
argument que à guyancourt justement les
locaux sont mises à disposition par la
ville
donc la question des économies sur les
locaux on peut la balayer tout de suite
c'est une mise à disposition par la
ville
or c'est justement cette mise à
disposition tu répondais voix à français
dominaient quand vous entendez ça alors
je lui réponds que les locaux tels
qu'ils existent actuellement et son
premier saut était de les maintenir en
l'état ça ne répondent pas au cahier des
charges
étant donné cette nouvelle offre de
services et les locaux qu'ils mettent à
disposition justement je les ai étudié
parce que je pense que les guyancourt
toise ça leur importe peu de savoir sur
quel périmètre est située la pmi savoir
si c'est à guyancourt où à montigny ce
qui compte pour elle c'est que la paix
me soit accessible et là je crois que
vraiment il faut avoir conscience de la
réalité du terrain la réalité du terrain
c'est quoi c'est que une maman qui a sa
poussée de charger avec un enfant deux
enfants elle elle peut pas elle peut pas
marcher
de manière déraisonnable et en
l'occurrence le choix de l'emplacement
proposé par le département est beaucoup
plus pertinent que les choix de monsieur
de ligne et pour lesquels aux 10-15
minutes de bus il faut rajouter 10
minutes de marche alors que
l'emplacement du département en trois
minutes
voilà la maman elle et elle est dans son
centre de pmi alors à guyancourt il ya
une pmi pour 23 mille habitants
aujourd'hui c'est 1000 consultations par
an si elle fermait cela ferait une pmi
pour soixante mille habitants alors même
si c'est peut-être mieux desservis si
les centres soit la mieux choisi est-ce
que ça suffira vraiment oui ça suffira
puisqu'il n'y a pas de suppression des
heures ni de consultation pour les
médecins ni de permanence pour les
puéricultrices et bien merci laurence
rôle fut d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et d'être venu en plateau
pour nous parler justement de cette
réorganisation de l'ap et eni bleus
c'était la couleur qu'avait choisie
plusieurs communes des yvelines la
semaine dernière une semaine bleue ou
troisième âge était tel honneur
l'objectif lutter contre le
cloisonnement des générations et faire
valoir le rôle de nos aînés chez dans la
société
les activités et des thèmes différents
selon chaque ville voici un focus sur la
semaine bleue à la dernière réalisée par
william elle devient alors vous pourrez
dire en vous faisant des rencontres
intergénérationnelles à la verrière le
statut disparaît ici pas d'enfants de
personnes âgées que l'on ait dix ans 70
aujourd'hui tous sont citoyens du monde
permettent à des enfants et à des
seniors de réfléchir de co réfléchir où
chacun est un interlocuteur valable
où chacun a quelque chose à apporter à
l'autre c'est d'une extrême richesse
l'exercice du jour s'exprimer chacun son
tour sur une question philosophique
aujourd'hui on parle de rêve et quelle
que soit la génération les réponses ne
sont pas si différentes
gervais bac
les personnages y sont a complètement
différent des enfants j'ai appris que
des fois nous on fait on fait des rêves
et qu'on perd ce cas nous et que eux ils
pensent à touvre plein de personnes
juste que je suis quand même surpris ses
enfants il y en a quand même qu'ils ont
qui savent réfléchir camani bon yaya de
l'éphémère mais aucun des enfants qui
recherchent quand même et nous devons
leur apporter notre notre expérience de
notre vécu une semaine bleue ponctuée
d'activités en tous genres pour le
troisième âge ici un tout autre exercice
petite initiation au self défense ces
retraités se prête volontiers au jeu
mais admet tout de même ne pas être
vraiment à l'aise avec ces techniques
pour une femme oui ça serait peut-être
plus difficile ce dossier défend can am
je vais peut-être me traîner mais malgré
les difficultés rencontrées la bonne
humeur reste palpable
une semaine qui a ravi tous les
participants mais qui surtout la
meilleure occasion de revaloriser les
seniors dans notre société et ce
week-end se déroulait la 13e édition de
l'exposition armanet à montigny le
bretonneux et l'exposition organisée par
le lion's club de montigny les trois
villages au profit de la lutte contre la
maladie d'alzheimer
la maltraitance et le handicap sephora
namani et patrick jacques de dixmude
christophe baudin aliens lebesque cote
ont fait partie des 52 artistes français
réunis pour la 13e édition de
l'exposition armanet à montigny le
bretonneux samedi dimanche dernier leur
inscription été reversés à un fonds pour
lutter contre la maladie d'alzheimer
le handicap et la maltraitance ça fait
des années que je le fais c'était aussi
ma première exposition de requins un
côté sentimental entre guillemets et
également il faut savoir qu'il est
les inscriptions sont reversés pour la
lutte contre la maladie d'alzheimer qui
est une bonne chose je trouve une bonne
action et jeu tout à fait partie de
l'état d'esprit de générosité qui à mon
avis est nécessaire quand on fait de la
peinture et l'art je m'attache à faire
des choses ludiques soit avec des
enfants avec de la couleur avec beaucoup
de mouvement parce qu'avant je
travaillais dans la danse et pour moi
c'est très important qu'il y ait du
mouvement même si c'est une sculpture
faut pas que ça soit statique
peintures sculptures aux photographies
d'art pouvait être admirés lors de cette
exposition
trois prix ont été remis à la fin du
week end un prix du public un prêt du
lion de ce club et un prix de la ville
décerné à christophe baudin nous avons
cinquante deux artistes présents avec un
niveau qui montrent de plus en plus le
public hier était assez assez satisfait
c'est ce que le retour et ce qui y est
très encourageant pour nous c'est dès
que le public nous dit effectivement ça
monte de plus en plus c'est bravo 6000
euros ont été récoltés cette année par
le lions club de montigny au profit de
la bonne cause l'association espère
recueillir encore davantage l'an
prochain avec une édition d'arman et
internationale l'exposition accueillera
des artistes belges et un mode sport de
football pour finir l'équipe de maurepas
retrouver ce dimanche que le chemin du
championnat excellence contre vallée 78
une semaine seulement après son
élimination en coupe de france sur leur
pelouse du stade du bout du clos les
murs bazian ont concédé le match nul de
vie partout elle résumé des michael et
demi d'euros du retour au quotidien pour
au bord pas les verts jouer ce dimanche
en championnat excellence après leur
épopée en coupe de france leur défaite
au 5e tour contre boulogne billancourt
au stade du bout des clos les morts
casernes ont pu faire mieux qu'un match
nul d'un but partout contre vallée 78
une équipe qui pointe pourtant la 10e
place du classement
on n'est pas rentré dedans
montant pas en bon état d'esprit je sais
pas où nos têtes étaient mais c'était
pas dans son championnat donc enfin
leurs coûts continuent à bauchi voilà
qu'on a fait une belle une belle
aventure en coupe de france maintenant
on savait qu'il fallait qu'on se
reconcentre pour le championnat et voilà
on est on l'a dit avant le bas sur l'a10
à la mi-temps pense qu'on n'a pas encore
fait assez les efforts pour pour gagner
ce match à la maison quoi dans ce match
haché et son rythme le défenseur central
et capitaine fabien perrot a réalisé une
partie convaincante solide dans les airs
et dans ses interventions le mort d'asia
également égalisé juste avant la mi
temps avec un but plein d'opportunisme
je vais vous en faire un but en renard
des surfaces n'est pas trop mon style
mais voyez un coup franc qui est dévié
au premier poteau et puis j'arrive bien
à la suivre je dois tout juste du bout
du pied ce qu'il faut donc voilà après
j'aurais préféré que que les copains
marque deux buts pour qu'on puisse
remporter ce match mais voilà c'est
toujours toujours un plaisir en tout cas
marquer dans un match et au classement
maurepas et dernier du championnat
excellence avec deux matches en retard
prochaine rencontre pour les verts le
dimanche 1er novembre rencontre le ch
est né un derby qu'il faudra remporter
pour le pas sont bonnes et on leur
souhaite bon courage à la scène mort pas
je suis sûr qu'ils vont remonter
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite rester
avec nous avec nous vous avez rendez
vous avec noureddine à une pour le 7-8
société sur le thème du logement social
je vous retrouve demain à 18 heures pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
en direct je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée